good morning believe nation today's
message is push through over to you
Bradley Cooper between those things you
also went to Broadway with Julia Roberts
with Paul Rudd three days of rain that
must have been pretty special yeah it
was a do-or-die moment for me actually I
think Kitchen Confidential had gotten
canceled you know I and and I remember
thinking if this doesn't work maybe I'm
not right for this business I thought I
thought that their moments in life
anything like you know it kind of does
matter if this fails or you fail in it
and and it was hard it was one of them
it was the hardest thing I've ever been
through by far and I remember thinking
if I can get through this it'll it'll
maybe as hard but there's it's
impossible for it to be harder and it's
true and it's and I've had a lot of hard
time since and more jobs you know when
you're like wow the pressure is so
intense but it always I have such a
foundation for three days gonna say that
eight shows a week right not even that
actually was the rehearsal process and
not to do once we got on stage it flew
and that thank God and I thought oh this
feels right but it was a you know and I
was hard on myself you know but it was
just man it was tough the toughest
decision I ever had to make in my life I
told this to a couple times but I was 19
years old I had opportunity to do my
dream job what I thought I always wanted
you know 80 hundred thousand dollars
starting salary flying around the world
doing banking doing consulting the
thinking I thought I always wanted to do
versus being in this business where I
was making $300 a month and not able to
survive and I really didn't know what
the best option was I really didn't know
what I should do and the thing that
saved me the thing that got me through
was I didn't want to live with regret I
didn't want to look back five years
later ten years later seven years later
I think I really wish that I did that
and and I feel like I backed away cuz I
was afraid I didn't want that to happen
and I felt like you know what I can
always go back and get another job in a
year and
be the same job mean I'd be the perfect
job but I can always go back need
another nose job
where this business wouldn't be there
for me in a year and so I said I'm gonna
give myself a year and I'm gonna go out
and try and do it and I never looked
back and never had to go get a job that
was the hardest decision I ever had to
make
it's easy to talk about it now and make
it sound simple but it wasn't but every
single decision had to make sense has
been way easier I put it through the
same framework through the same thought
process of am I gonna regret this if I'm
scared of doing something am I gonna
regret not doing it and as soon as I ask
myself that question as soon as I
realize that I'm gonna say yeah I might
regret this that I have to do it even if
it doesn't work out it's great that this
worked out right it's great that my
entrepreneur career worked out but maybe
I wouldn't have I'd be okay with that
too I don't want to be okay with not
knowing I need to know and so I think
going through that really tough decision
making process helped me in all future
decisions and I think whatever you're
going through right now understand that
it will help you for your future
endeavors so the next time something
gets tough you'll you'll easily be able
to walk through it where the people
around you will crumble and so the
hardest decisions I've had to make sense
I've been a lot easier because I've
already gone through I've already gone
through in my mind the hardest decision
I'm ever gonna have to make and every
other tough decision becomes easier and
easier and easier and easier the more
that I work that muscle so the question
today today is I'm curious what's the
hardest thing that you you I've ever had
to push through leave in the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events VESA Oh
let's pray so give me go